man: So hi, Brian.
Welcome.
And maybe you could
talk a little bit
about what application
you're presenting
here at Google I/O.
McRae: Uh, yeah.
Well, my name's Brian McRae.
I'm the founder, creator,
director
of Crazy Pixel Productions.
We are a game developer
based in Orange County,
California.
We created the Island demo
for Google back in,
I believe it was February,
right?
We were, like,
one of the first
to really kind of
push the graphics there.
man: Yeah.
McRae: And currently
we are working
on a couple of other
demo projects,
one being a tower defense game
that we're really excited about.
man: So could you tell us--
tell us a little more
about the tower defense game.
Where is that headed
and what's it like?
McRae: Well, why don't I start
with where we were
and then where we're going.
So the first thing
we had to do
was, you know,
design the characters
and towers
and all that kinda thing.
And that was fun, you know.
The concept artists had
a really good time doing that.
Then it was--you know,
we needed to build
a sort of a model viewer
so that we could take
our 3-D assets,
put 'em into, you know,
the O3D canvas
and see what we're getting
material-wise
and all that kinda thing.
So that's the first thing
that we did.
Using a lot of the API demos
and whatnot,
we pieced it all together.
It just took like
two or three days.
And we were able to--
you know, just started going
through the iterative process
of building our objects,
exporting them out of
3D Studio MAX,
bringing them into O3D,
and, you know,
testing the materials,
the mesh, how it looked,
you know, against
the O3D light.
And even, you know,
bringing in objects
that had animation on them,
so the characters
and everything.
And we were able to load,
you know, characters
that have our own kind of
custom, you know, rigging
and bone system
and everything.
And found it to be
very sort of forgiving.
man: Awesome.
So I'm curious,
you came to Google I/O
to present your application.
But I'm wondering how have
you liked Google I/O in general
and have you learned
about any new technologies
or things that you're thinking
about using in the future?
McRae: You know,
I think there's a lot
of, you know, avenues
that the O3D could go.
We've done some work with
a web developing company
that does a lot
of product renders
and that kind of thing,
you know, shopping carts.
And so we've done, you know,
high-end product renders
for, you know,
various companies.
And we always wind up
having the camera, you know,
pointed at it and render
all the way around,
and then use Flash
to kind of get, like,
a 360 degree view, you know,
as real-time as possible
in the viewport using Flash.
And I think
with something like this,
it'd be really interesting
to, you know,
have those, you know,
crazy next gen shaders
showing everything off
as realistic as possible
using photo source
as the textures and everything,
get really realistic
results in these products
as they're being shown in 3-D,
so the consumers could
really kind of see
exactly, you know,
what it looks like
just as they would
if they were in a store,
you know, 'cause you could
pick up the item
and look around at it
and everything.
You know, other than that,
we're a game studio.
So we love
to entertain people.
I think there's
a lot of opportunity there
to, you know, create sort of
engaging experiences,
you know, traveling through,
you know,
through 3-D space,
interacting with other people,
you know.
I don't know,
maybe even an MMO,
something crazy like that.
man: That would be
awesome to see.
Yeah, we look forward
to seeing more content
from you guys.
And I'm wondering, you know,
as people have passed by
and looked at the awesome stuff
that you guys have created,
what's the general response
that people have had?
And any particularly
interesting comments
you've gotten from people?
McRae: Right, well,
with the Island demo,
because we wanted
to push the graphics
as far as we did--
and you helped us out
with the shaders
and everything there--
the response has been,
you know--
We were at the Developers'
Sandbox yesterday showing it,
and a lot of people just
looking up at it.
man: Nice.
McRae: And that to me
is a really great compliment,
when people just see
an environment
and become mesmerized by it
and just, you know,
engaged into it.
So I'm really excited
about, you know,
just seeing how far
we could push things,
'cause that was just
the first attempt.
You know, usually,
you know,
from a game developer's
standpoint, you know,
for like Xbox
or Xbox 360,
when you get to the end
of the cycle,
that's when you really start
finding out what's possible.
We're just in the beginning
right now.
So I think once we start
adding in fog,
ambient occlusion, you know,
all these other, like,
next gen graphical gizmos,
we could really see
where this thing is going.
man: Awesome.
Well, thanks a lot, Brian.
And we look forward
to seeing what's next
with the tower defense game.
McRae: Sure, yeah,
it was a pleasure to be here.
I think we're also going to be
involved in a blog
so that we could share,
you know, our experiences
of O3D on there.
And we're also planning to just
have some assets available
for other users,
you know, developers,
to just take some assets,
put 'em together
and, you know, generate
their own, you know,
applications or whatever
with O3D.
man: 3-D mash-ups.
McRae: Yeah.
man: Sounds cool.
Well, thanks.
McRae: Yeah.
Thanks for having me.